I wish more than anything that I could  go back and redo my problem  [Music]  [Music]  then all of my other proms this is my  first time going to prom I feel if I  promise for everybody I don't think I've  ever felt this masculine in my entire  life I want them to look at me in st.  he's a homosexual I feel like I'm ready  to have a night and I don't never forget  it's not like I'm just going to prom to  go to promise I'm going to prom to go to  from I think the one thing that I'm  gonna take away from queer prom this  year was that I'm normal  I can honestly say for like the first  time in my life like I actually feel  beautiful just still be yourself and  shine as bright as all of the colors in  our rainbow  never be that's we're like ghosts are  the same kind of stuff that we have each  other no matter where we come from don't  be afraid to put yourself out there  having gone through this experience to  definitely boosted my confidence and  made me feel more like me  [Music]